and about benefits and the the pros and
cons if you like of the Dow in speakers
corner now obviously this is a very it's
some of a subjective discussion there
will be people that fall on both sides
some people say that it's more negatives
and to say there's more positives
generally would you acknowledge both
that there is an issue yes underlying
there which is that Muslims generally
speaking are not adopting what you're
saying which is good characteristics and
good mannerisms in conveying the message
there yes 100% look the thing is what
happens is look there's pros and cons
yeah I believe generally the the pros
outweigh because globally watched yeah
and a lot of times people yes they hear
the arguments etc Muslims Iman they want
to hear it you know they use these
arguments and apply it in their dow as
well it's good you know but what we
forget is that yes you're empowering the
Muslims etc but it's not gonna come at
the cost of okay you're preserving yet
was it magic said you're preserving the
capital but it's important that for
example while you do in the in
preserving the Muslims yeah you're
losing that new commerce yeah yeah so
now this has to be balanced when you're
going to the speaker's corner you see is
that Transformus you transform you know
it's like a robbery transform it's
because the thing is is that what I've
realized as a Salama organization the
reason why we call it sharing affection
love and mercy is that because we want
to change them and we really want to
change that we our our you know our
philosophy you can say is let people see
Islam let no people here Islam you let
people see Islam in our actions and this
is one of the biggest thing that is
lacking
and a lot bombers in the park because
they come across people that Erica and
or have an ego where if it maybe what
they do is they transform into the
occasion for that person to meet them on
their level on them level now allah says
in the quran repel evil with good yeah
sometimes okay you need to repel evil
with evil sometimes yeah obvious about
the best is almost want allah tells us
but like a person that david would he
need somebody like hijab yeah exactly to
have transformed quite well yeah yeah
like well here's the thing on that point
I think is
just to just sorry we're cutting you
because I think what you said is
important so there may be a a certain
time where you have to adopt a certain
yes approach in yes speaking to someone
right but that's not the norm yes you
have to make that see that's why when
his job was having a discussion before
the debate for example we knew he knew
yeah we said to him and he knows himself
that he even said it and when he was
havin debate he said he's not James
White yes he was James oh he made that
clarification just make that very clear
yeah yeah because this person is
somebody that mocks the Dean lies about
the profane insults him
yeah dress up like a woman yeah and it
does all these kind of stuff so this guy
deserves our treatment absolute if
anybody to come in and say the hey
cheffy was Erica I totally disagree yeah
I've done a beautiful job there it was
it's very surface these Christians that
look at David what would I wanna see
well I would say it's worse in many ways
because it's unfortunate here's an
individual that's supposedly following
the Christian tradition
it comes across in such a nasty and in a
rubber tree waiting to watch human being
and I think these Christians Brothers
Christians out there that recognize this
and and actually like James my exactly
more and they don't they don't consider
him of course never get any authority
favors didn't victim for but well but I
think another point is to clarify his
book the issue that happens is someone
made me so hijab and this could they
clarify this James well yes someone may
see every debate like that or another
debate speakers corner where the Muslims
a bit more no there should be no excuse
for having bad manners and bad
magistrates yes obviously at times you
can come across more more assertive yeah
and more forceful but still maintaining
good characters among yeah yeah very
true now but unfortunately that doesn't
happen in most many is in some cases but
what ends up happening sometimes is
someone some young Muslim brother or
sister is watching this debate on online
and they think okay they take the points
but they also take the characteristics
and they apply to John down the road
right which is a problem you know so how
did you try counter this what do you do
personally tax account that's what I was
going to say you know that's why when I
said for example need in a specific
person that's arrogant yeah and you're
talking to em in that manner what
speaker's corner does is because it's a
routine because you see we I've been
watching some like videos on the
subconscious mind yeah because
subconsciously what you're doing is your
program in yourself every Sunday you're
going there and you're talking to this
person
what's happening now is that you're
carrying that not only forget that were
you're taking that home yeah you're with
the wife and you start jumping some you
know the fabulous hug you miss you
already what's your premise your premise
is wrong and we're talking about you get
it you it's cool its problem everywhere
so that's the reason why you have to
like have a detox yes yes I see it
yourself okay calm down
sometimes I'll see a genuine person and
look at the Bravo speaking the David
would like it really hurts me I'm like
you're actually ruining what you're
doing like being frustrated let it be
sometimes we need to understand this
causes damage this arrogant behavior
Janna look the Dow is bigger than your
ego it's bigger than your ego if you
feel how are they offended me I need to
put them in their place you have some
problems in your head yeah you know and
sometimes were our fault for that
I'm but the think it's spot the
weaknesses and try to work on it yeah I
try my best to sometimes I was having a
discussion with one lady yes and I was
speaking to her before that her friend
came he was insulting the Prophet
literally insulting the Prophet and I
didn't drop to a level I just turned my
back to her yeah yeah
and she went on a mad one mm-hmm after
that talk to her yeah and kind of put in
a place yeah I'm sorry cuz she's
insulting the Prophet yeah
she went yeah her friend came my friend
was more soft and I need to know now why
I did it off okay be together and I
started a bit Rocco and then free I can
even show you the video and then I
stopped and I said madam can you give me
a second I said yeah I said I'm sorry
she's a white I said along those lines I
said sorry I just had to be talk in the
moment cuz I had to just okay this is
not her ally come back to your senses
this is somebody maybe genuinely want to
know I had to you know take you know
transform myself because what happens is
it can get caught up ease in here
you know solution I can see it you know
know this was a person and it was sad
because she said that her dad abused her
and that hurt me yeah you know and I
thought to myself on a lot imagine if I
came down like no than another you're
gonna make you worse